This video is part of a series that
expands on the basics of historical
linguistics by exploring various
types of regular sound changes.
Today's sound changes assimilation.
Two sounds are involved here and one
of them becomes more like the other.
The assimilating phoneme picks up one or
more of the features of another nearby
phoning the Latin root.
Sim is the key here.
The two sounds become more similar.
You've learned about phonemes
and their features in my series,
the IPA for language of learning,
the place of articulation and manner of
articulation of consonants will come in
especially handy for the basics of
assimilation. Let's take an example.
The Latin phoneme.
Doug has the features dental plosive and
voiced the phoneme s has the features,
Alveolar fricative,
the Latin word,
odd prefixed to the word Simi.
[inaudible] results in the
pronunciation as see me Latier.
In other words,
d comes to share all the features of the
nearby s and is completely assimilated
to s
okay.
Speakers of languages the world over
use a simulation to make words easier to
pronounce for ease of articulation.
There are different types of assimilation.
Does d assimilating sound take on every
feature of the phoneme that triggered
assimilation? If so, the
assimilation is complete.
If it only takes on some of,
or even just one of the features,
that's only a partial assimilation.
The assimilation in the Latin, uh,
see me laugh too.
Above is complete,
but when I pronounce and
as em before p and input,
that's a partial assimilation.
Okay.
The two sounds are both by label, but
one's a nasal and the other's a plosive.
Okay.
Are the two sounds side by side,
we'll call that contiguous assimilation.
Are they more distant from each other?
Not adjacent. That's non-contiguous.
The two examples of assimilation I
have given you both involved contiguous
phonemes.
If my tongue gets twisted
and I accidentally say a
Russian shoved marine for
Russian submarine,
the assimilation is non-contiguous.
Does the change sound come after the
sound it's assimilating to that's a
regressive assimilation or is it heard
before the sound it's assimilating to
that would be a progressive assimilation.
My embarrassing mispronunciation in
Russian submarine is an instance of a
regressive assimilation,
but the assimilation of n two and input
is a fine example of a progressive
assimilation.
We can also label assimilations by the
features that are changed in the process.
If the assimilating phoneme
is originally voiceless,
does it pick up the feature
of voice from the other sound?
This sound changes called voicing.
Nearly all vowels in
human language are voiced.
Consonants often become
voiced between valves.
Some Italian speakers pronounced the
phonemes or as between two vowels asZ ,
like in Lamea causa my house.
The change from s two Z is an
instance of interval Kalik voicing.
If the assimilated phoneme is voiced,
does it pick up the feature voiceless
from the other sound or from being at the
end of a word? That's the opposite
phenomenon called d voicing,
so the word have ends in
the voiced phoneme vote.
The word too begins with the
voiceless t. Some speakers, Dee voice,
the two foot when they pronounce
the expression, have to as Hafta
does the assimilating sound move its place
of articulation closer to the palate.
This happens when the sound
it's assimilating to already
has a palatal or near
palatable place of articulation.
This is called palatalization and
it's significant triggers include the
consonant. Yeah, and the
vowel e. For instance,
some English speakers pronounced the
word student as student in rapid speech.
The alveolar to assimilate to the
palatal. Yeah, and becomes palatable.
Vilar Chuck student does the
assimilating sound change its manner of
articulation so that the airflow
is closer to a fricative.
This is fricking to visitation and
less restricted sounds triggered.
This kind of change including fricatives
and valves stops often undergo this
assimilation.
I've both heard and said
the mispronunciation up
through four up through that
pronunciation.
Fricker devices,
the plosive puck as it is simulates
to the fricative for of course,
the phoneme can assimilate to any
place or manner of articulation.
I won't list all of them here.
Further examples of assimilation to
specific places of articulation include
Labor utilization.
When the assimilating sound
becomes more lady and valorization.
When the assimilating sound becomes
more Vilar when it comes to matters of
articulation, the assimilating sound can
become a plosive and African and so on.
There's an opposing change
known as this simulation.
Two sounds are involved here too,
but one becomes less like the other.
The disseminating phoneme loses one or
more of the features that shares with
another nearby phoning the two
phonemes more dissimilar. As a result,
the English phoneme is a
voiceless by Labor stop.
If you say Peter Piper picked a peck
of pickled peppers as fast as you can,
chances are you dissimilate one or
more piece by pronouncing them as an f.
Here becomes less like the surrounding
piece by turning from a stop and do a
fricative, but there are more
serious examples in language history.
The Latin root pedagogian getting comes
into English as pilgrim rather than peer
grim.
The first are dissimilar rates to an l.
The simulation has the same
characteristics found in assimilation.
They can be progressive or regressive
contiguous or non-contiguous involve
voicing or d voicing and et cetera.
The one consistent difference is that
this process involves two sounds becoming
less alike.
That's all for assimilation
and dissimilation watch
again next time when I'll go
over the kinds of sound changes that
involve adding and getting rid of south.